it's been acting up you take a 6/8 wing  man out of the VEX  Moscato PCEHR without sacrifice you  point line over his last five games  coming into this one it is that he's  able to get the assist hook her inside  attempt in a pocket pass to bein snapped  away by the quick hands of Bazemore CJ  has dispatched Damian of three upright  and the two teams met came out in that  second half 29 points torture the sun's  looks like more of the same so far  [Applause]  up to four come CJ make that Damien at  the top of the arc gets off this island  grows to three Damian Lillard with the  three-pointer soon  I mean he's picking him up the entire  way name showing you the ball handling  [Applause]  Dave tried to shake Devon Carter parts  of three up and in Damian a little red  high-rolling Lillard right now locked on  automatic 404 steps up send another one  a day why not baby  Lillard five for five all from three